[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
موطني
[موسيقى]
الجلال والج
مال
والسناء والبه
[موسيقى]
اء في رباه
والحياه
والنجاه
والهناء والرجاء
[موسيقى]
فيها
هواء
الاراك الاران
[تصفيق]
ب
وغانما مكرما
سالما
مناعبا وظلما مكرما
واعرف
هااه كامله
موطني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
موطني
[موسيقى]
الشباب لن يكن همه ان يستقل
نستقيمين الرادار ولم نكون للعشاء
[موسيقى]
كلا
بي لا ن
ريد
ذلنا المفضل
عشناها عشنا
نريد
بل نعيد
مجددا
مجدنا
تريد موطني
شكرا
[تصفيق]
شكرا كتير
[موسيقى]
البلاد كروم زيتون ودو
وصف للطب ميتها دواء
البلاد ذكرهم زيتونه دواء
لي
[موسيقى]
الصوت
يا صوت الريح بالكرمله
دواء لي
حسبت الكون موسيقى وت
رايب
حاليا
اويلي اويلي اويلي اوي
له
بابا يلا كلنا سوا وين غرامات
مسافر وين غرامات
ما تخاف الله ما تخافيش ماما
[موسيقى]
والله يا مسافر
عاشور
[موسيقى]
يا حبيبي وين يا حبيبي
باركني ورايح وين يا حبيبي حس
وا ونظري ونصيبي
الله
سبحانه
ما تخافش منك قوي
هيه يا حبيبي
هيه هيه هيه
يلا علشان الزغروته
يا مسافر زعلانه
واشهد
[موسيقى]
يبوس لنا
منها علمها ان شاء الله يا رب
عديني
واتحنكي عيوني من دونك عينك الله
حبيبي ولا تنسى الناس لك يلا مع السلامه
[موسيقى]
هلا هلا هلا هلا
قويه مركب الهند
[موسيقى]
ولذاكر
رايح على الغربه وبلادك احسن لك
يا رمضان
صل على النبي
يوم الغربه شاعر راسي شعب يلا
[موسيقى]
صفوان
اوسكار
شكرا
كثير لكل من دعمني في مسيره الفنيه شكرا
كثير احلى تفليكه شكرا
يعطيكم الف عافيه يا غالي
[تصفيق]
تحدد صعوبات كثير في حياتها لحتى وصلت
لمرحله انها قدرت تدخل المجال الفن اللي
كان صعب انها انسان زيها توصل له حصلت على
درجه اولى والمستوى الاول في دفعتها في
جامعه بيرزيت في الموسيقى كل الاحترام لها
شكرا وما زالت قاعده في حلومها كل
الاحترام لك يارا وان شاء الله بنشوف
البوماتك واغنياتك واغنيتك الوطنيه لارض
فلسطين لكل الفلسطينيين يعطيك الف عافيه
[تصفيق]